this is the dominant side of the yonkyo
form from shomanuchi
here exactly like i come in and i'm able
to dominate him and control
underneath again similar to how we saw
in the sankyo form once i get him to
touch i can't get him down
so he can't quite rise but i can't get
him down we're going to stand still here
i step in because i know he's now under
control i bend his arm 90 degrees
pull my thumb out and slide my hand back
now as i slide my hand into this yoke
position
as he comes up he'll actually apply yom
kyo for himself
uh to himself and as he feels that he's
gonna shoot forward just a little bit
i use that moment to quickly drive him
the rest of the way down
here my inside leg is right next to him
i push his elbow forward this is going
to go into his shoulder
i'm still applying the yonko and i begin
to twist his wrist or his arm in this
motion
one more time to speed
oh